in the opening scene we are introduced
to a Seattle police officer named Edward
malice who is patrolling the highway on
his bike during this a doll falls out of
a running car in front of him being the
good cop that he is Edward picks up the
doll using his Ghost Rider Riz and
approaches the car to return it
unfortunately as soon as he hands it to
the owner she throws it back again what
what are you doing kid and when he goes
to retrieve the doll a truck suddenly
crashes into the car causing it to burst
into flames Edward quickly rushes to
their aid but the car explodes throwing
him away the scene then cuts to a few
days later where we see Edward on leave
as he is still haunted by the tragic
accident he constantly has the
hallucinations of the same event which
disturbs his mental health as a result
of this he has prescribed some medicine
one day he receives a letter from his
ex-fiancee Willow Woodward informing him
that her daughter Rowan has gone missing
so she wants his help in finding the
little girl Edward thinks about it for a
while as he had been trade and hurt
numerous times by Willow in the past but
still he decides to assist her in
finding her daughter the very next day
Edward boards a seaplane Ahoy there he
says to the captain like a jackass he
travels to an island off the coast of
Washington state where Willow resides
the island appears to be inhabited by a
group of neo-pagans led by an elderly
woman named sister summersile whom the
residents worship as a goddess the
village is predominantly populated by
women and men are treated as slaves
Edward is dropped off at the coast from
where he begins walking toward the
village along the way he encounters a
group of villagers to whom he inquires
about Rowan but they evade his questions
he also notices two women carrying a
large bag with blood-like liquid
dripping from it he asks them about the
same but in response they only make fun
of him after a while of walking Edward
arrives at a rural Motel where he
declares himself as a police officer and
announces that he is here to investigate
the missing child case in the midst of
this Edward kills a b on the table
causing everyone to stare at him with
anger little does he know that bee honey
is the main exporter product of the
village so the villagers perform a
fertility ritual every year for growing
crops and honey shortly after Willow
enters the motel and shows him to his
room later that day Edward and Willow
have a secret meeting in the woods she
expresses her gratitude to Edward for
agreeing to help and warns him that the
villagers will attempt to deceive him
she then requests him to have faith in
her because she is confident that Rowan
is captured and hidden somewhere in the
villa after hearing all this Edward
assures her that he will do everything
in his power to locate her daughter the
same night while Edward is asleep he is
a dream involving the girl from the
previous accident this jolts him awake
prompting him to take his medication at
that moment he notices a girl who
resembles Rowan running outside the
motel Edward quickly rushes out and
follows her to a barn inside he searches
the entire Place thoroughly but only
finds the girl's Red Jacket while on his
quest he steps on a weak wooden plank
which causes him to almost fall into the
basement he's dangling like
the following day Edward visits the
Village School where he meets a teacher
named Sister Rose who is in the middle
of a class he interrupts the class and
inquires about Rowan however everyone
feigns ignorance regarding her
whereabouts suspecting that they are
hiding something Edward retrieves the
class register without sister Rose's
permission and examines the student
names to his surprise he discovers
Rowan's name crossed out Edward opens a
desk to see if she's inside but a bird
pops out and Edward goes hey in response
Sister Rose insists on speaking with
Edward outside after a brief
conversation about the islander's
perspective on death she reveals that
Rowan is no longer alive Edward asks
about the cause of her death and Rose
replies she'll burn to death when Edward
catches the tents she used Rose quickly
corrects herself by saying she burned to
death in addition she informs Edward
that the child has been buried in the
churchyard in the next scene Edward
makes his way to the churchyard where he
is approached by Willow she asserts with
conviction that Rowan is still alive and
the villagers under sister Summer's
isle's command have taken her away and
are trying to harm her in a shocking
turn of events willow also reveals that
Rowan's biological father is none other
than Edward
um Dad what do you mean what do you mean
after this she leads him to Rowan's room
recounting the last time she saw her
daughter at her study desk on that
fateful day Willow had stepped out for a
mere half hour and by the time she
returned Rowan as well as all her
belongings were mysteriously gone Edward
inquires if there are any other
photographs of the child but Willow
responds in the negative shortly after
as Edward is investigating the room he
hears the sound of a seaplane prompting
him to hurry outside in hopes of using
its radio to contact his colleagues in
Seattle for assistance beside the
seaplane Edward calls out to the pilot
but his calls go unanswered at the same
time he spots the lifeless body of a
young girl floating in the water
believing it to be Rowan he impulsively
Dives in and retrieves the body however
in a sudden Moment of clarity he
realizes it was a hallucination Edward
then realizes that he has forgotten to
take his medication so he swiftly
retrieves the bottle from his pocket and
consumes it following this he swims
towards the seaplane to access its radio
only to discover that it is not
functioning as Edward returns
empty-handed he comes across the house
of Dr T H Moss a physician and
photographer in the village he knocks on
the door hoping to find a picture of the
missing child however just like the
others Dr Moss pretends to know nothing
about it Edward who is well aware of the
deception acts as if he is leaving but
instead conceals himself behind a bush
outside after a short while two women
wearing face masks arrive at Dr Moss's
door and take him along with them once
they depart Edward breaks into the house
and thoroughly searches every room
during his exploration he uncovers
evidence of a ritual involving Human
Sacrifice which the villagers appear to
believe in on investigating further
Edward finds several glass beakers
containing male human embryos shocked
and Confused Edward goes to Willow and
inquires about the ritual but even she
lacks sufficient knowledge about it with
this Edward decides to visit the senior
most person on the island sister
Summer's Isle as he makes his way
towards her he comes across some men
loading wood onto a cart Edward
generously lends a hand and attempts to
strike up a conversation but the men
don't utter a word seems that they are
forbidden from engaging in any
conversation as a pair of masked women
vigilantly monitor their every move
undeterred Edward continues on his
journey lost in his own thoughts these
women are crazy however his
preoccupation leads to an unfortunate
mishap as he accidentally collides with
one of the beehives in the vicinity
instantly a swarm of angry bees
surrounds him Edward attempts to run
away from them but only ends up tumbling
down a steep hill knocking himself out
after some time he opens his eyes and
realizes that he is now in Sister
summersile's place he then finally meets
with her in the garden and begins to
question her about the events happening
in the village sister summerzial
explains to Edward that her ancestors
fled England to escape persecution and
then settled on this island she also
states that their population is
predominantly female as they chose the
strongest stock the Island's economy
relies on the production of local honey
but Edward learns that its production is
recently declined out of the blue he
asks if they have murdered Rowan to
which she responds that they don't
murder anyone but sacrifice them to the
gods this angers Edward who argues that
human sacrifice is also a form of murder
in order to confirm whether the missing
kid is truly dead Edward decides to
exhume the grave as he does so he
surprisingly discovers that the coffin
contains only a burnt doll indicating
that Ron is still alive just then Edward
hears a crying voice coming from an
underground bunker prompting him to
follow the sound as he descends he
discovers an entrance leading to an
underground water tank inside the water
he finds Rowan's distinctive Red Jacket
alarmed Edward frantically opens the lid
and dives into the water but someone
from behind locks the lid trapping him
in the tank Edward desperately calls for
help but his cries go unheard the night
passes and Edward remains clinging to
the lid of the tank thankfully early the
next morning Willow spots him and frees
him from the trap Edward then shows her
Rowan's red jacket and doll as evidence
that she was held captive here not long
after Edward becomes aware that today is
the May Day Festival on the island and
the villagers are preparing to perform a
fertility ritual this realization fills
him with panic as he believes that they
are about to sacrifice Rowan as a result
he urges Willow to stay at home safely
while he searches the entire Village for
their daughter he even visits a local
coffee shop and seeks assistance from
the male villagers but they completely
disregard him left with no other option
Edward goes to Sister Beach who works at
the same Motel he stayed at he uh
incapacitates her steals her bear
costume and joins the parade led by
Sister somersile blending in as one of
the Island's inhabitants before long
Edward notices that Rowan is tied to a
large tree seemingly destined for
sacrifice without wasting any time he
rescues her bravely and then escapes
into the woods the shot of Nick Cage
punching a lady dressed as a bear is the
clip that initially made me fall in love
with YouTube after fleeing for some time
Edward appears to be lost so Rowan leads
the way shockingly she leads him back to
sister summersile and the kid reunites
with her mother who stands alongside the
so-called goddess in a shocking twist
sister summer zile thanks Rowan for her
assistance and Edward realizes that the
search for Rowan was a premeditated trap
the whole time it is then unveiled that
Willow known on the island as sister
Willow is none other than sister
summersile's daughter she had
orchestrated Edward's fate Years Ago by
choosing him as a human sacrifice in
order to restore the Island's cursed
honey production this Revelation
devastates Edward as he once again
experiences betrayal from his former
fiancee following this the villagers
gradually encircle Edward closing in on
him he brings out his gun threatening to
shoot all of them but Willow reveals
that she has removed all the bullets
from his weapon the villagers then
tackle and overpower Edward cruelly
breaking his legs to ensure he cannot
Escape they also subject him to extreme
torment by releasing the bees upon him
if you've ever watched me on Twitter you
know I goddamn love this scene a few
moments later they carry him to an
enormous doll which they refer to as the
Wicker man where he is hoisted high
above the ground and locked inside with
Willow's consent Rowan ignites the
Wicker man and Edward is sacrificed in a
colossal Inferno all as his screams echo
through the air killing me won't bring
back your Goddamn money
[Music]
scene then shifts to six months later
depicting sister Willow and sister honey
in a bar within Washington there they
are approached by two police officers
one of whom recently graduated from the
police academy the women invite them to
their home presumably to entice them to
the island just like they did to Edward
James Franco is about to get into almost
as much trouble as he did in real life
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching